bonsoir marine le pen merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur un peu en avance alors
vous l'avez entendu avec nous
l'information d'assaut vrai c'est bien
sûr le conseil scientifique qui
préconise le prolongement du confinement
rien d'officiel pour l'instant mais est
ce que c'est une préconisation qui vous
semble logique
non mais écoutez quand le confinement
est décidé et que le gouvernement a
indiqué qu'il durerait qu'un jour
pas une seule personne de la communauté
médicale ne savais pas qu'en réalité ils
tueraient entre aux vingt quatre à six
semaines
donc là il ya eu un choix stratégique du
gouvernement de mentir aux français ou
de les infantiliser en se disant on va
les préparer psychologiquement disant
d'abord 15 jours puis en rallongeant ce
délai moi je considère que c'est une
erreur
moi je pense toujours qu'il faut parler
aux français comme un peuple majeur un
peuple responsable et qu'il faut lui
dire la vérité c'est dans la vérité et
dans la transparence que naît la
confiance or toute une série de choix de
communication du gouvernement ou en
réalité créé là des fientes et la
défiance elle ne va pas dans le sens du
respect des instructions qui sont
données par le gouvernement
alors aujourd'hui le conseil
scientifique a donné d'autres
préconisations l'une d'elles c'est les
couvre-feux nocturnes qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
je pense que normalement on est tous
confinés si vous voulez donc par
définition tout à sortir le jour donc a
fortiori on peut pas sortir la nuit donc
qui sort la nuit ce sont ceux qui ne
respectent pas le confinement
donc je ne vois pas ce qui peut poser
comme problème aux honnêtes gens qu'il y
ait des couvre-feux entre 22 heures et 6
heures du matin sauf bien sûr pour les
gens qui travaillent à des activité
essentielle pour l'état aux soignants je
pense que ça facilite le travail
honnêtement de la police pour faire
respecter les mesures de confinement qui
devrait être normalement respectés par
tous alors certains maires ont préconisé
déconfinement chez eux enfin plutôt des
couvre-feux chez eux notamment à béziers
à montpellier ou encore à nice
est ce que votre avis et aux élus locaux
injustement de d'encadrer ces couvre feu
ou alors c'est à l'état non c'est à
l'état évidemment
et si vous voulez vous aurez noté que
depuis un mois et demi si vous voulez
l'activité essentielle du gouvernement
consiste à ouvrir le parapluie en a
tellement que les parapluies de
cherbourg là à ancrer des comités
scientifiques que des comités de
recherche des comités des comités tout
ça en réalité ce sont des structures qui
permettent aux politiques d'échapper à
leurs responsabilités et on a presque eu
le sentiment que le gouvernement met
plus d'énergie à tenter d'échapper à sa
responsabilité et accessoires et
accessoirement à préparer d'après ce que
nous dit notre confrère de rtl
la réélection des manuels macron là car
prendre des décisions urgentes qu'ils
doivent prendre et sur lequel ils ont
déjà pris énormément de retard
alors marine le pen j'aimerais évoquer
avec vous les solutions à qu'on entend
ici et là pour combattre ce coronavirus
on parle énormément de cette molécule de
chloroquine qui est généralement utilisé
dans le traitement du paludisme
hier le ministre de la santé a autorisé
l'utilisation de cette molécule pour les
formes graves du coronavirus mais les
scientifiques qu'il utilise ne fait pas
ne fait plus en tout cas partie
du conseil scientifique c'est un peu
paradoxal c'est à dire que moi je ne
comprends pas trop le gouvernement moi
je me réjouis et je les dis que de cette
piste prometteuse mais je suis pas
médecin je ne sais pas si ce traitement
véritablement et celui encore une fois
que les français attendent et que le
monde en réalité
attendons qu'il y ait des études qu'ils
soient effectués en urgence c'est à dire
peut-être plus rapidement qu'elles ne
sont faites en règle générale pour
mettre un médicament sur le marché
oui bien sûr je le souhaite je l'espère
et a entendu qu'on a beaucoup de recul
quand même des décennies de recul sur ce
médicament
mais ce que je ne comprends pas et que
ceux qui ont émis le caractère positif
de cette molécule
il ya évidemment professeur raoul temps
en france mais avant lui il y avait
aussi les chinois qui ont fait un
certain nombre d'études sur la
chloroquine disent qu'en réalité elle
fonctionne surtout pour empêcher des
symptômes qui sont bénins ou graves de
devenir très grave et qu'elle fonctionne
plutôt moins bien pour les quatre qui
sont déjà très atteints or le
gouvernement vient nous dire bah on va
autoriser une étude mais on ne la
donnera cojo qui sont très atteints donc
moi qui ne suis pas médecin
j'ai du mal à comprendre ce choix fait
par le gouvernement
maintenant toutes les pistes que doivent
être travaillés tous les médicaments
possible ne doivent être faire l'objet
d'études pour qu' on puisse évidemment
sortir avec un traitement va toucher ça
que tout le monde attend alors
aujourd'hui comme hier on a vu des
scènes assez particulière à marseille
ces longues files d'attentes devant
l'institut justement pour être dépistées
est ce que vous comprenez le choix de
ces personnes de se vouloir se faire
dépister est-ce que ce choix ne va pas à
l'encontre des recommandations de l'état
justement de ne pas sortir de chez soi
ou l'équipement moi j'ai trouvé ces
images inquiétantes
voilà je ne vous le cache pas pourquoi
parce que le confinement laquelle l
intérêt du confinement est que pendant
un certain nombre de semaines plus
personne ne saurait donc plus personne
normalement dans contaminent d'autres et
que ainsi on tue en réalité l'épidémie a
passé nous le nom des gens se
rassemblent que ce soit d'ailleurs sur
des marchés où que ce soit dans des
files d'attentes
on prend le risque que cette
contamination continuent donc je trouve
effectivement assez j'ai trouvé assez
étonnante
ces images et j'avoue que je m'interroge
sur l'utilité dans une huile alors que
tout le pays est concerné d'opérer
c'était maintenant que les choses soient
claires dès le départ je pensais qu'il
fallait testé massivement les gens dès
qu'ils avaient des symptômes dès que
vous avez même une suspicion de
symptômes
il fallait évidemment les tester
pourquoi parce qu'à partir du moment où
ils étaient testés positifs il se
confinait eux mêmes et ils empêchaient
la propagation
or où on n'a pas fait ce choix là par
pénurie ou par al compétences on a
choisi de ne tester que les gens qui
étaient déjà qui avait déjà une forme
grave qui était pour une partie d'entre
eux hospitalisés
ça veut dire que peut-être il y a dix
fois plus de français
ou peut-être vingt fois plus de français
qui en réalité sont contaminés que les
chiffres officiels que donne monsieur
salomon tous les soirs tout en disant
qu'en réalité ils sont faux bond je
pense que là il ya eu une erreur
originelle si je puis me permettre
qui va évidemment cas évidemment rendu
de fait le confinement général un peu
obligatoire et marine le pen comment
vous expliquez que la france en termes
de dépistage
on en parle soit en retard par rapport à
des pays comme la corée du sud tout
comme l'islande
je ne me l'expliqué pas nous avons le
sentiment que nous découvrons qu'en fait
nous sommes un pays sous développés en
matière de santé est la question que
tous les français se posent croyez moi
depuis un mois et demi c'est où va notre
argent parce que c'est en même temps le
pays qui est un des pays les plus
taxer où les habitants sont les plus
taxés où ils payent le plus d'un pont et
on se pose la question de savoir où vont
tous ses impôts puisque il n'y a pas
assez de lits d'hôpitaux il n'y a pas
cette fois niant les soignants sont mal
payés il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de
stock de masques
il n'y a pas de production de masse
qu'il n'y a pas de gel hydroalcoolique
il n'y a pas de tests à disposition
objectivement c'est vertigineux ce qu'on
découvre en réalité à l'occasion de
cette crise sanitaire
alors la française ne dispose pas de
stock est nécessaire de masquer un pour
faire face à cette épidémie une
commission d enquête parlementaire est
elle nécessaire afin de faire la lumière
sur ce que certains qualifient de faute
grave ou même de scandale d'état
une oui bien sûr au moins au moins à une
commission denquête même si je pense que
les tribunaux sont saisis en réalité car
il y a la une
incontestablement une carence une faille
dans le le le conduire le fonctionnement
de l'état aujourd'hui on en est à
demander à des entreprises de fournir
des masques à des particuliers de
fournir des masques l'état clairement
démontre sa quarante dans sa capacité à
prévoir et accessoirement à prévoir le
pire parce que quand on dit gouverner
c'est prévoir
c'est évidemment prévoir le pire pour
que le pire n'arrive pas bon or on voit
bien que l'état a été encore une fois
défaillant mais il a été défaillant dans
des prises de décisions politiques car
s'il n'y ait plus de stocks de masques
quand on s'en rend compte au moins de
janvier immédiatement l'état aurait dû
faire des commandes
immédiatement ils auraient dû
réquisitionner les les entreprises de
production
immédiatement il aurait dû demander à
des entreprises qui avaient la capacité
de réorienter leur production pour faire
des masques de le faire or tout ça n'a
pas été fait donc on a perdu des mois
en attendant et bien les soignants sont
en danger
les gendarmes sont en danger les
policiers sont en danger les personnes
qui font le ménage dans les hôpitaux
sont en danger parce que je pense à elle
aussi à ce personnel de ménage dont on
ne parle pas mais qui elle aussi est au
contact du virus c'est-à-dire tous ceux
qui sont au front pour lutter contre ce
contre ce virus est bien ne sont pas
protégés ils ont pas les blues ils n'ont
pas les masses qu'ils ont pas les
lunettes
ils ont rien ils n'ont rien ils en sont
à fabriquer eux mêmes des marques avec
du tissu en papier ces infos fait
oublier qui ment marine le pen j'aurais
aimé parler avec vous la situation et la
gestion de la crise par l'union
européenne on sait que la russie la
chine et cuba ont apporté leur aide à
l'italie mais pas l'europe la pandémie
passé est ce que l'union européenne
devra rendre des comptes à l'union
prévient l'union européenne premier mort
dû coronavirus articule permettre car la
l'union européenne a démontré son
incapacité totale à apporter la moindre
réaction
la moindre solidarité la moindre aide et
même pire elle a donné des instructions
qui était d instruction moi je le porte
mortel aux nations la première
intervention de l'union européenne a été
d'interdire quasiment en tout cas de
conseiller vivement nations européennes
de ne pas limiter la circulation des
personnes
c'est gravissime car la première chose
que l'on fait quand on est confronté à
une épidémie qu'elle soit d'ailleurs
humaine végétale ou animale
c'est évidemment de maîtriser
immédiatement les frontières pour
empêcher la dissémination de l'épidémie
aurait l'air ghislain verte pourquoi
parce qu'elle est idéologues parce que
le la libre circulation est une religion
et que même la mort n'arrive pas à
convaincre ses dirigeants qu'il faut''
évidemment pour une période donnée fermé
des frontières pour éviter que des gens
en provenance de
région qui sont touchés par le virus
puisse venir
et puis disséminer le virus et c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé en europe
quand cette épidémie sera terminé
quelles vont être les leçons que la
france et l'europe vont pouvoir tirer de
cet épisode dramatique
je crois que l'europe ne tirera aucune
leçon pour une raison simple fait
qu'elle ne réfléchit pas de manière
rationnelle
je viens de vous en apporter la
démonstration en train quand je dis
l'europe c'est l'union européenne mais
les nations européennes elles l ont
elles devront très probablement appris
de cette crise appris que la
mondialisation n'est pas heureuse appris
que il faut conserver évidemment d état
stratège que oui bien entendu quand il
s'agit de la santé on ne peut pas
délocaliser et permettre et comme soit
dépendant à 80 ou 90% de la production
de matériel de protection de d'oxygène
de médicaments elle elle va apprendre
cela c'est la fin si je me permets du
nouveau monde que vantait emmanuel
macron avant même qu'il ait pu le faire
démarrer
en réalité c'est la fin de la vision à
mon sens ultralibérale c'est le grand
retour de l'état
c'est le grand retour des nations mais
c'est aussi le grand retour du collectif
pas ce sentiment que l'on a d'appartenir
à des peuples qui s'entraide entre eux
mais qui assurent leur propre protection
dans leurs propres frontières avec
toujours cette fraternité qui existera
entre les différents peuples européens
mais aussi peuples du monde car
l'épidémie n'a pas fini de se répandre
et évidemment je suis également très
inquiète des continents qui sont
aujourd'hui à peu près préservé mais qui
risque voir arriver la vague du tsunami
comme l'afrique
merci beaucoup aux marine le pen d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir sur arte france
marine le pen
ou présidente du rassemblement à
nationale